so now you also had some interaction
interactions at least at arm's length
with with escher
oh yeah yeah so what i read was that you
and you and your father had been
interested in escher's work
and you worked out with him
the
ever ascending staircase
which by the way seems to me quite
similar especially to the music in box
third brandenburg concerto which and i
talked to a musician this week about how
bach managed to make this continual
ascending spiral that never really goes
up that's true there is a thing like
that yeah right yes
so and then you sent the drawings of the
staircase to asher
well the story was a little bit longer
than that because i i had been at this
i was a graduate student i think in my
second year i can't quite remember and i
and the colleague went to amsterdam to
go to the international congress of
mathematicians which happened every four
years
and at this congress
i happened to see one of my lecturers
and he had a catalogue which had one of
these action pictures and what on earth
is that you see and he said well this
exhibition in the fangoth museum
by this artist m.c escher never heard of
him before i went to see the exhibition
i was absolutely blown over by these
pictures
one in particular i think was called
relativity
and i came away thinking
gosh that's amazing
i wonder whether i could do something a
little bit different that i hadn't
actually seen in in the exhibition
and there so i tried to make a
construction with bridges and roads
going into possible ways
and i simplified it down to this thing
that people refer to as a tri-bar i've
seen the tri-bar and uh i showed my
father i mean i didn't know that there's
a
swedish
artist called oscar writes fired who had
done things very similar earlier
but
escher didn't know about him either but
anyway um and there are other artists
who've done things like if you look
carefully in in the old
there's a breeze which which has a
picture of gallows and they're it's
joined up differently in the top yes
i've seen that i've seen that picture
so there are other people who had played
with these ideas but i hadn't quite seen
it in isha
and so my father and i wrote an article
he he developed this the staircase was
his actually
he was designing buildings and then he
produced the staircase which went round
and round
and we decided to write a paper on this
we had no idea what the subject was what
journal did we send it to so my father
said well i happen to know the editor of
the british journal of psychology so
let's call it psychology
so we sent it to them
and they accepted it he said he thought
he could get the attitude to accept it
they did and this was we gave reference
to ash's the catalogue and the
tuesh's exhibition
and then my father had a con
correspondence with airship with letters
going backwards and forwards
and then i think i
was
in driving in the netherlands for some
other conference i think
and i was curious and i
when i was reasonably close to esther i
phoned him up i got the phone number for
my father
and he was very nice and he invited me
and my then wife
to uh to tea and and he
i just had a chat with him and
he he sat at one end of a long table i
was the other end and he had two piles
of prince and he said well this pile
i don't have many left i'm afraid
and he pushed the other part of me
choose one
so i sort of went through these things
and i picked one out pretty hard to
choose one out of all that
and i chose one called fish and scales
[__]
he was actually rather pleased because
he said well most people don't
understand that one
so i [__] bit flattered by that
but this
i then gave him a set of little
pieces of
just one shape
and
i
i gave him a set of them and said well
can you tile with those
and then a little while later he wrote
to me and said he'd
seen how to do it but he wants to know
what the
underlying principle was
so i did i wouldn't pray that was a very
bad correspondence it took me a little
while before i got back to him but i
showed him the the
what it was based on and on the
basis of that he produced what i believe
with his last
watercolor maybe for this last picture
as far as i know i think called
ghosts
which is based on on this uh
it's the only tiling as far as i know
that he ever did which is what's called
non-isohedral
you see you usually did periodic ones
but they're periodic in the strong sense
that if you find a shape
the next time you see it it has the same
relation to the pattern as a whole so
you could
move this one into that shape and the
whole pattern goes with it into itself
but the one i showed him was what's
called non-isohedral that you can have
different instances of the shape
so this one has a different relation to
the pattern as a whole
from that one
and so if i move this one into that i
can't bring the whole pattern
along with it
so you have two different
roles that the shape plays in the last
one of his pictures
showed this
so i'm i'm curious too so
this
about about two things now i'm
interested in why
you're so fascinated by the relationship
of a geometric shape that can be arrayed
in a variety of different manners to
this underlying problem of mapping like
so you're reducing
you're reducing or establishing a
relationship between the problem of
mapping a large terrain
to
the utilization of
like
very stringently defined
what would you call them
representational systems or
that's a geometric form what what is the
geometric form
conceptually
in relationship to the problem of
mapping
well you have a shape and then you have
certain rules about which
pieces will fit next to it
but there's certain freedom in that rule
you could put this one that way or
another way you see
and
you know if it's just if it's
a shape which very clearly has to fit
that way next to it then it just repeats
you see but if there's some freedom as
to what the next one will do
then you might have to make that choice
and certain choices will run you into
difficulties later
and other choices maybe will allow you
to continue
is there a relationship that between
that and what composers do with music
because i mean there's a certain well
there's a certain repeating determinancy
in music but obviously a composer just
doesn't take a pattern and repeat it
indefinitely they take a pattern and the
pattern seems to allow for some choice
in movement from that pattern forward
well maybe i don't know i mean it said
this i mean what makes a piece of music
into a good piece of music
i mean i have no idea that's that's a
much deeper issue
well we do know we do know a bit about
it we know that if it's
too simple and repetitive it you your
interest gets exhausted yes exactly it
gets stale very rapidly and then
as it moves towards purely unpredictable
it becomes indistinguishable from noise
so there's some place in between there
and you could probably move on that
place where you get
some ultimately harmonious relationship
of predictable form and
well something like the play of novelty
that seems to me to be analogous to that
possibility of shifting the shapes in
this tiling problem i mean i think music
is tiling something yeah it's a
representational form no that's probably
some connection it's just that music
and there's so much more freedom as to
what you do you you see with it's with
these tiling shapes it's forced on you
that you know either it fits or it
doesn't you see it with music
it's much more subtle
right i would i would hate to make too
much of a
elite yeah yeah yeah yeah fair enough
one more question along that line now
that that triangle you made
yes now what's the relationship between
those paradoxical forms and the tiling
problem
not much
because they seem to be they they're i
mean there's a play of of representation
an image there i mean one of the things
i've been wondering i looked at all your
diverse contributions and i thought wow
there's a lot of things happening in a
lot of different places but there must
be some there's something that's not
random
there's something at work
that's kind of a uniting principle that
might be i don't know it might be the
problem that you're trying to solve in
some
in in some deepest way that's uniting
all these elements of exploration and
interest
i don't know you're asking too hard a
question i don't know i mean sometimes
i don't see any overriding principle
i mean there's a sort of thing
you know something feels right now why
do you why does it feel right i mean
that could be
something very subtle
yeah yeah maybe wrong too or maybe maybe
they are wrong that yes yes
it seems to me that that also is related
in some important sense psychologically
to that notion of understanding you know
the feeling that it's right it's it's
like it's interesting that it can be
wrong but it's also interesting that it
can be a predictor
of i got a student a student she was
very creative
and she would come up with hypotheses
that were damn good
but
she was more creative than the typical
psychologist and i don't say that in a
denigrating way i mean she was more like
an artist than a researcher
and then what she would do is spend like
six months writing out the algorithmic
pathway to that conclusion even though
that is not how she derived it but she
had a pretty unerring ability to jump
forward to the right place with her
intuition and it's something like i
think it's something like a deep form of
pattern recognition you know you don't
need the full pattern to infer what the
pattern might be you can have a sparse
representation of it leap to what might
be analogous to a tiling solution i
suppose and that that seems to be
something related to the accuracy of
intuition